[Music]
the Fox a while back asked a question
that I thought would kind of get you
going uh the Fox on YouTube says does
anyone even play titanfall 2 anymore Oh
[Laughter]
yesterday frontier defense update
released for titanfall to explain what
it is to us and why it's one of the
bigger updates aside from what was the
new Titan a new Titan was monarch yeah
aside from honors why is this one of the
bigger updates to titanfall 2 in the
year or so that it's been out good
question good question
it implements four player co-op your
horde mode if you will and it's probably
one of the best keep together it's
probably one of the best horde modes
I've ever played like it's like
sometimes those can be you know kind of
slapped onto a game but like here it's
like it's really very separate as well
and we'll get into more about that I
guess but like it's you know it's a
completely different feature as far as
like your progression you know you have
these things called aegis ranks right
where there are specific to your Titan
so the more you play as a specific Titan
you kind of increasingly build up
different types of abilities that are
really very much game changers they're
kind of Opie's stuff but then we start
getting into the higher difficulties of
this mode and you realize you need them
yes correct
well that's the cool thing I here's how
I think it can happen and just to give
an idea of like what one of these
abilities would be is like you there's
like twelve ranks I think so someone
like scourge is it nine from what I saw
yes okay nine it's my memory is X so one
of the like second the last ability for
scorch who has a very slow fire rate
with his thermite launcher one of the
last ones is you can fire three
consecutively without having to reload
which is huge for someone like that
usually horse a lot
scorch is great scorch is great and that
for me yes I know you use one the only
like aspects of the game that I like a
really big buff so people say and I were
doing this live stream yesterday which
is really fun it's it's funny to see all
these the community is really great and
and fun to to see progress where people
are called
now Papa Scorch yeah and you just hear
all these puns and people just love you
know their their main and and and they'd
like to kind of have you know very fun
there's fanfiction oh I'm sure anyway
spore we talked about cheese
so yeah just rank is specific the
frontier defend right but you're all
your other progression is consistent
across PvP and this right so you can
upgrade like my Ronin who's the one I've
been working on he was level like 14
when I first got into it and I ranked
him up to 17 the aegis rank does not
those like more powerful abilities and
attacks don't factor into PvP stuff but
for now they don't right there was a
hard time believing they ever will those
are pretty well big euro you're
absolutely right and then I was thinking
about it too and I see it as just if
they do implement into PvP it would be
its own mode right yeah you would you
would definitely have to keep it
separate yeah it's like iron banner and
destiny or something that takes into
account those kind of imbalancing
abilities could be it's really fun and
its really fun so yeah you you know you
have these waves they're five waves they
get increasingly more difficult as you
can you have enemy types that have the
wheeled mortars so you the the premise
of the horde mode is that you have a
harvester that you need to protect and
if it's destroyed then you lose and you
have three retries to survive five mode
so you have yeah these enemy types like
mortars that are like further away from
your harvester that are kind of you know
learning you out on your top yeah you
have to take them out or else they'll
rain havoc on your harvester and then so
so I had played in order to get to that
there's there's four difficulties easy
regular hard and master I played there's
an insane I thought it's probably it's
like it's weird it's like a whole
separate difficulty I don't even know
what that's like but because you have to
actually level up your aegis rank so in
order to get to hard you have to have I
think a rank of 5 or 10 I believe and a
and I just did for the sake of the
stream we just did regular and or just
regular mode and it was by the end of it
we were actually as it's kind of easy
then I tried hard mode in my god
was crawling by the end of it and that's
what I really really enjoyed and I and
it was really difficult and you start
seeing all these implemented aspects of
like the any enemy tight especially for
Titans like I Mikey you were talking
about so here you can see a scorch with
a nuclear or no Allegiant with a nuclear
icon over it meaning nuclear ejection so
when you destroy him he's gonna explode
and do an insane amount of damage if you
don't take out those guys prior to them
getting in the vicinity of your
harvester you're gonna lose you have to
take those guys out quickly because they
will wreck your Harvester yeah and so by
in hard mode by like the last wave it's
just an onslaught like a dozen of these
guys and it's so panic inducing and just
fun and so yeah you you're strategizing
here you know like many other hard modes
you you know in between rounds you're
buying arc traps you see their turrets
you're you know you're getting strategic
and putting the our tracks and our traps
and lanes there's one there on the
bottom the bottom left that's nuclear
you if you rodeo a Titan when you get
off you immediately call us him to
explode yeah so that is kind of pushing
you to get out and down the lanes as
quick as possible to get out and take
out these nuclear Titans the thing I
like about this DLC is it actually makes
me rethink house my loadouts work so I'm
definitely gonna I mean how many loadout
slots do you get higher up levels I
don't know I'm sure like my 9 and 10
slots I'll make specifically for
frontier defense because I told you
haven't working on Ronan and you said
there are some Titans that have that you
could see right here the mark the arc
electricity surrounding them and they
face torment cuz Ronan's move into close
quarters yeah so but also when I get
might when i unlock my sword core for
ronan which is like his you know
ultimate so to speak he you know like
there's four titans coming down a lane
whereas in multiplayer i'd save that for
when i can take out one or two enemies
and I'll kind of be conservative about
it because I don't want to just die in
this I'll be the only one that Lane the
other three people will be off doing
their own thing and I'll activate it
kind of you know more arbitrarily or not
arbitrarily more you know on a whim
right away because I need to defend them
for that so it then there is also like
I'm anti
weapons are much bigger now or not much
bigger but I use them much more plus
they've revamped the weapon system
earlier so you could have two you have
the sidearm and I tighten reasoning
which one of the biggest gripes of this
update because they are there they're
always changing balancing the one thing
I see a lot of people commenting on is
that they actually nerfed a lot of the
almost all of the pistols which is kind
of a bust I'm having that slot now and
it's like great I don't there's no one
using it so this is always cool when you
so you you know you have actually
infinite response so it's just about
keeping your harvester life so here you
are like entering on a dropship you know
doing damage from above if they even
added the drones which I totally forgot
we're in the single-player drone enemy
types that are they come in and waves so
you just see them coming around over a
buildings and just flocking in you just
hose them down reminds me of like this
is a weird comparison but it reminds me
of like Matrix Revolutions just those
sentinels coming at you and they're
Titan just like those those were in the
first one - at the end well just that
the ending battle they have in the yeah
the desire was I on whatever yeah
anyways
Nebuchadnezzar yeah and the other the
other great that's a tough word to say
good job the other name
the other cool thing is that you have
different types of waves you know maybe
you'll get again like nuclear Titans
coming in or just a bunch of grunts
they're very specific to Maps so there
are five Lee five Maps currently they'll
implement the mode and two other ones
down the road and this is the new map
rise from the first game which people
love but they're they're very
specifically you were telling me and I
had played in just until yesterday the
black water canal map mm-hmm they which
has the big canal in the middle the
enemy waves filter through and down that
one lane under the bridge
yeah and in downtown the wind the waves
cater to that so they're different I
guess I'm trying to say it's each math
is very different as far as strategy
goes yeah and this one seems much less
Lane based the one I'm watching right
now oh it's got like three main lanes I
mean they all Oh Maps economy the lack
water just very very very like three
approaches aside from the mortar guys we
can go over rooftops yeah
the things I kept telling you is I
really want to play with friends and
have voice chat because it's pretty key
like it's really really team work
centric yeah we're like you want to have
as you said loadouts to write like you
know you think you like cloak but now I
was realizing which is a an ability that
I know would never use as a wall where
it's like I just put down my a wall and
I could be that defensive player and
just use like anti-titan what's a shield
for those who don't know a shield but
when you you output through it it does a
damage boost yeah like beautiful so that
would be a role and another role would
be like I'm gonna I'm gonna get down
early and like take out these Titans but
yeah it's very team centric and I think
it's super fun and unique and if you
know if you again drift it off from the
multiplayer because you thought it was a
little too competitive or difficult this
is like a whole new way and yeah playing
this game yeah lion peach and the
YouTube chat I was just saying it's
funny that this released the same week
as like Titan falls or sorry for
tonight's soft-launched to wave defense
things obviously zombie Chronicles came
out recently seems like it's not a
resurgence I don't think wave defense
kind of survivals ever went anywhere but
it is funny
we'll talk more about fortnight later
but it's funny that a titanfall to
update does wave defense better than
fortnight in my opinion oh wow in a few
ways but that's not the best like the
fairest comparison but they are going
for part of their for next design is
wave defense and I'm having much more
fun with titanfall tube's wave defense
titanfall 2 is also a really good
example of games that are really really
supporting their communities after
launch there's overwatch you have like
Ubisoft has been doing really well to
the division they made much better
Rainbow six siege like double its player
base eight months after or something
yeah it's it's really great like I again
like the subreddit of the games that I
am obsessed with and look into the sub
reddits like that sober it is so cool to
see like the one of developers be the
kind of spokesperson and like post the
patch notes we're also doing QA like if
when people are being vocal about
changes that they don't like it's just a
very like healthy conversation like
there's never a post that's like are you
booking you know like any kind of like
bashing or swearing or being like overly
aggressive force we need
James you see like get nasty you know
they completely listen to their fans
every time like yeah like tumble see did
that to where they released a patch
because people were like not beating
that game like 0.8 percent of people
beat that game or something like that
they were like alright we heard you guys
it's too difficult and they wrote this
whole thing out the developers and it's
just it's nice to have that open channel
like a they're listening and then they
it's more of a conversation rather than
just people yelling into a void right
thing like it wasn't too hard I hate
this yeah I have to be like players
versus developers right yeah right we
both want this game to be good yeah yeah
it's I'm interested to see it's not the
same developer obviously but battlefront
2 is gonna have free DLC as well so I'm
interested to see how they how EA kind
of implements that stuff as far as EA is
concerned as the publisher of both games
you know you know deal scene you know or
updates post launch you know they need
to make money obviously and title is
really great about separating out with
cosmetics like I'm always like happy to
give that five dollars for a skin again
having all the updates be free like it
also big people want to just pick up the
game if maybe they didn't see anything
there they wanted before it's like geez
when this came out it was one thing but
it's a totally different thing now so
maybe I'll buy it yeah you could play
just frontier defense and still write
level up in the same progression system
plus they just system totally and I
respond to some guy I think on YouTube
who was like is this worth picking up
and it's like some guy said it best was
like I I'm pretty sure he's right but
the game is $20 I think for ps4 right
now really I think so 20 I don't know I
entered across any like market I don't
know exactly where he was looking I mean
I had to double-check that there was
like a big PlayStation sale yeah $20
like if it's not twenties probably 30 I
don't know like yeah for this mode alone
right like it's just freaking cool man
like I can't recommend it enough
honestly cool yeah so that is available
on PC Xbox one ps4 all three platforms
like Rob is saying it's well worth
playing even if you might not have been
tied fall to before it's well worth
jumping back into and it's a good
supplement to the PvP if it's PvP stuff
which I've been playing pretty regularly
since it launched last October
and they're so yeah they're celeb dating
it seems like every month it almost like
some kind of update plus Papa's scorch
got a buff Papa's scorch that was the
funniest part about the stream Jay
talking some guy like basically I would
butcher it but he basically did like
this is your no he turned the DiGiorno
motto into like pops chords I don't know
it's not see I've been thinking that
Papa Roach this I feel like you need an
ability or something called last resort
and there's gonna be more up to Titans
down the road to like you know they're
really I'm pretty sure at least one more
than what was the melee based one that
they saw in the files just like that
punches people bison bison yes because
you know there are three yeah there are
Latino three chaste he's like they just
did one the kind of medium build with
monarch like I would expect Timur
[Music]